I would tell people that in my heart I want
to stop with these military interventions.
In my heart I don't wanna send our men and
service women to lose their lives.
And I don't want them to be responsible for
what ultimately are thousands of innocent
people being killed in these countries.
So Hillary Clinton dots the Is and crosses
the Ts on all of the pol- all of the names
and everything associated with this, but as
a result of that we have the foreign policy
that we have right now, that I have to tell
you: I think is horrible, horrible!
And that's how I would answer it tonight.
I would be mad, I would be angry, I would
be angry that people would be calling me out
on the names or geographic locations, names
of foreign leaders, when the underlying policy
has thousands of people dying.
And that is unacceptable.
This is the Gary Johnson that you would have
seen in the debates.
It angers me to no end.
Because what I'm saying, I think, echoes what
most people think.
That what we do is ridiculous.
What we do is abhorrent.
Because that has to do everything- to do everything
with the fact that,
that both of them are vilified.
Both of them are unpopular.
60% of Americans view them negatively.
I think it's pretty clear that we don't have
a qualitative problem with the ticket, we
have only a quantitative problem, which is
getting known by
50% of the electorate instead of 30%.
And if we go to 50% recognition, we'll go
to 25% ballot preference because Gary doesn't
have the negatives that the two major party
candidates seem to have.
It's pretty straightforward.
Well, you know, we tell our story.
It's a matter of going around and trying to
persuade the national media, among others,
as well as the people that we see every day
that we offer an alternative to the two establishment
parties and that we're fiscally responsible
and that we're socially inclusive.
Both of which things we've proved to our 2
terms, each of us, in office.
So the difference between us and brand A and
brand B is that we've been there and done
that and nobody can argue that we didn't change
our states.
And we were Republican governors in Democratic
states so, by definition, we had to work across
the aisle to get our programs enacted.
And we did it, we both moved our states in
more conservative directions fiscally.
Nobody can dispute that.
So, you know, hope is not a plan.
We have a plan and it's to do what we have
already done.
Well I think that we, because of the tools
that we do have available, Twitter being right
at the top of the list, that we are able to
communicate.
And thank you for that.
So this really is a year of social media.
It's not a year where bought and paid for
advertising in the last weeks of the campaign
is gonna swing the election because people
will tune that out.
You know, once you get past 1215 gross rating
points per week so every man, woman, dog and
cat has heard the ad, you know, 17 times.
People are gonna say 'no'.
And I think decisions get made virally, social
media and across the fence.
We have- We have understood today that Hillary
is spending 18 million dollars right now
to discredit us.
That is more money then we will end up, probably,
having in the campaign to conduct our campaign.
That it's- That it's just, it's horrible.
Why would you even say that?
We're giving people a chance to vote for something
as opposed to the lesser of two evils.
That's what we are- that's what we are providing.
First Vote.
You wanna waste your vote with Hillary or
Clin- or Trump,
go right ahead and waste your vote.
We're not spoilers we are the first vote.
Last question, please, anybody else?
So I guess we should drop out.
Is that what you're saying, is that your editorial
here is that we should drop out?
Another way of putting it is that this is
a year when the voters really, because of
a constellation of stars, the voters do have
to think for themselves.
And we think if they do think for themselves
that they'll recognize that we're the highway
up the middle, which is fiscally conservative
and socially liberal which is about 60% of
the people in the United States.
In business terms that's a pretty good addressable
market.
So it's a question of getting that story out
there, we'd love to be on the stage tonight,
but failing that we're grateful for the chance
to tell our story through this medium.
I do.
I absolutely believe that if we were just
given top line polling that we would be in
the debates.
Thanks so much guys, really appreciate it.